The easiest way to get started with
Kubernetes is to use a Kubes detail
run and command.
Let's use a Kubes detail run and
command to launch a single
instance of the nginx container.
As you can see, Kubernetes has
created what is called a deployment.
We'll explain more about
deployments later, but for now,
all you need to know is that
deployments keep our pods up and
running even when
the nodes they run on fail.
In Kubernetes, all containers
run in what's called a pod.
Use the kubectl get pods command,
to view the running nginx container.
Now that the nginx container is running,
we can expose it outside of Kubernetes
using the kubectl expose command.
So what just happened?
Behind the scenes, Kubernetes created an
external load balancer with a public IP
address attached to it.
Any client who hits that public IP
address will be routed to the pods
behind the service.
In this case,
that would be the nginx pod.
So if we list our services now,
we'll see that we have
a public IP that we can use to
hit the nginx container remotely.
And there you go.
Kubernetes supports an easy to
use workflow out of the box using
the kubectl run and expose commands.
Now that you've seen
a quick tour of Kubernetes,
it's time to dive into each of
the components and abstractions.